صهيب ما الذي يحدث في المغرب المغرب حتى
الان زلزال اوقع حوالي 5000 ضحيه 2500
قتيل والعدد مقارب للمصابين الزلزال وقع
في اقليم الحوز الجنوب اقليم مراكش او
مدينه مراكش هذه المدينه المعروفه اكثر
المدن سياحه في افريقيا هذه المدينه بنيت
قبل الف عام تقريبا وبالتالي هناك ابنيه
جدا قديمه بعضها تساقطت جدران هذه الابنيه
القديمه وبالتالي كانت الخسائر التاريخيه
ايضا اللافته للنظر الزلزال وقع او بؤره
الزلزال كانت في منطقه جبليه لمحاذاه جبال
الاطلس هذه السلسله جبال قويه تربط بين
المغرب والجزائر وتونس وبالتالي هذه
المناطق عاده ما تكون قرى متناثره هذا ما
جعل عدد الضحايا قليل نسبيا مقارنه بزلازل
اخرى نعلم ان المغرب وقع في هذا الزلزال
عام 1960 وكان عنيفا للغايه في منطقه
اغادير التي لا تبعد الى حوالي 130 كم عن
موقع هذا الزلزال في الحوز وذلك الزلزال
في اغادير سقط فيه اكثر من خمسه عشر الفا
قتيلا وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن زلزال قوي
صحيح وصل الى سبعه درجات على مقياس ريختر
ولكنه ليس بالزلزال الكبير او المدمر الذي
ساعد في ذلك الطبيعه الجغرافيه للمنطقه
عدد السكان القليل لتلك المناطق البيوت
المتناثره لا يوجد بنايات شاهقه وبالتالي
جعل عدد الضحايا قليل نسبيا ولكن في
المقابل هذه الطبيعه الجغرافيه جعلت من
الصعوبه بمكان لفرق الانقاذ الوصول الى
الناجين او عمليات البحث والانقاذ كانت
صعبه نسبيا بسبب الطبيعه الجغرافيه
بمناسبه عمليات البحث والانقاذ عدد من
الدول العربيه والغربيه ارسلت مساعدات
وفتحت جسر جوي من المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ
من كل الدول العالم تقريبا وفق السلطات
المغربيه فهناك حوالي 60 الى 70 دوله
شاركت في عمليات الانقاذ والعمليات جاريه
الان للبحث عن جين تحت الانقاض في المغرب